been a fan of this man long before he
was a director of note i loved
i loved this man in the movie the last
seduction back in the 90s
uh and this was back when he was an
actor now he's one of the
best directors on the market and that
includes what i think is one of the
greatest super bowl commercials of all
time the nfl 100 commercial peter berg
good to see you good to see you and
thank you for those kind words it's a
fact
and i didn't even mention friday night
lights which is something that is still
my one of my favorite television shows
of all time that you were part of
as a producer and then you obviously
directed them just trying to keep up
with you
just trying to i appreciate that pete
all right let's get into the nfl 100
commercial how did you first
have this right across your i um
about literally three weeks before the
super bowl
um i was finishing up something in
boston
and i got a call from uh some friends of
mine that worked for the nfl
and work for an ad agent move quickly
when we need to we found a space
in downtown los angeles big sound stage
i thought it would be easier to get
everyone to come to one city
um and so they just i don't know how
tracy did it i mean i just just
i can't even think about the logistical
nightmare of all those plane tickets and
so this wasn't green screen everyone was
literally in the center everyone was
there
except for um we went to new orleans
i mean we went to new orleans for debris
and we went to
um to boston to get uh brady and baker
flew in to break
to to boston that's about to say i mean
if we were talking about three weeks
before the super bowl
we saw brees and camaro sit next to each
other that's right you had to go to them
to get that shot
and put it in that's correct and and and
they had just
lost to the rams and were not in good
moods
and that's when you shot it we shot that
after bree's
get lost to the rams right before the
super bowl so it was like
and when we had um you know todd gurley
like
running and cutting and um you know
and and people were like don't hurt him
and
you know i'm i mean it was it was it was
interesting because you know like
like my son who's a huge giants fan
um was on the set and he you know a lot
of people's kids miraculously decided
they wanted to work on this
training like my son and it was and but
suddenly like all of our kids are there
and they're just like
you know supposedly working but they
were just gawking and but um
my word um you know my big giants fan
fans and that the the last play of the
commercial is um
you know a pitch to sequon barkley and
then he hurdles a defender
and these guys were going hard like
ladainian thomason went
real hard i thought i knocked him
unconscious at one point some of them
were going really hard
barkley was hurdling and we did like
four or five takes
right there yeah and literally in the
fifth take my son
came back to the where i was working he
said okay that's it no more
you're not doing anymore you're not
doing that man and your son told you to
cut and you say
i'm not i'm not kidding this is this is
excessive you've got the shot
there's no point in you no no more
and this is 2019 to be played the giants
especially have a 20 you know we've got
a lot to prove
right and you know odell did a
one-handed catch and
uh my my son was concerned about that
um you know going through the table too
many times so he hold on a second pete
berg here on the rich housing show
when odell went up and he lit he went
through the table that was not any
so that was one that we may have done a
little visual effect on okay he went up
um and caught that's funny because uh so
we had a um
we had we had a lot of stunt guys there
and we had a stunt guy who was a
quarterback trying to throw it
so so odell could get up you know really
elevate and make one hand to catch and
odell fell into a pad
and then we we broke a table and we we
visually composite them there you go but
we couldn't get the throw right
and you know it's interesting that to
see
some of these players just so so such
fascinating guys and you know
um uh larry um larry fitz uh
fitzgerald was larry fitzgerald and
richard sherman
such curious human beings like they a
lot of the players would just come in
and leave
fitzgerald sat right by me for hours and
he wanted to understand how
you know how we do what we do and he
asked a thousand questions and we were
trying to get the throw
right for odell and our guy couldn't do
it and we went like 15 takes and larry's
like i got that she just walked in
looked at odell told odell what the
pattern and hit it one take perfectly
and odell fully extended and mary just
came back and sat
sat down with me i mean such a such a
nice guy and
um so wait a minute hold on a second
montana's in the room
all those quarterbacks brad shaw's in
the room yeah yeah
and so the the part where o'dell one
handed yeah
and um i'll tell you who can still throw
is kerry bradshaw
brad i mean bradshaw's throwing that
ball 50 yards
he was he kept hitting a chandelier that
was 50 yards away
and finally our product production
designer this guy neil spiezak was like
he's going to break the chandelier he's
got to stop and i mean people were
he terry bradshaw is uh i mean of
everyone his athlete him and um uh
barry sanders they're a lot of them i
mean ladainian was still going full out
but ladainian is a little young he's not
yet 40. no
bro uh um sanders and bradshaw were
probably the two
br and bradshaw of all of them if you
ask me who surprised me the most with
his athleticism
it was definitely terry bradshaw
bradshaw
yeah well and barry sanders i mean see
still he still had the spin moves
still i mean you can see in the
commercial he pulls up
spins and we had stunt doubles for
everyone you know we were very
mindful of not wanting to hurt anyone
and barry's like
no absolutely not i'll do i'll do this
um
and barry was was really athletic and
i mean one of the the cool things about
this commercial
it was obviously meant to be fun and it
was fun and i think it's very funny
but for for those of us that were there
that are football fans which
i'd say 99 of people in that room were
surprisingly emotional you know to see
saquon talking to franco harris
to see um um odell
talking to jerry rice and
the the the um the the transition the
totality of the experience to see
the young guys and jim brown and
everyone in between
you really kind of you know for me as
someone that grew up with football
i got to sort of have this timeline and
it was very emotional
experiencing these different players
that represented different
eras in football and different eras in
my life so
it was really i think one of the coolest
things i've ever done it was so
fun to watch people i'm telling you man
i mean just the reaction that people got
because first of all it's pretty neat
there's something called nfl 100 and you
want to talk about a great way to get it
out there that there's going to be a
100th anniversary the nfl
and then to see a lot of these players
just
have fun playing football on the ground
in a sport where we get so caught up
obviously rightfully so and this is an
important aspect for you
the health and safety of the game and
we're also caught up
sometimes in the replay we're caught up
sometimes in the minutiae that's right
so many people are gambling on it right
and they have that it really was all
about
football on the ground yeah the period
the game the purity of the experience
and
and that's what i liked about it and and
i struggle with
my market it can end okay
football is not a bad thing you know
there are elements that obviously
need to be looked at and should be
looked at like with anything else but
it was fun to just get out there and and
everybody got it you know like
all the players immediately understood
the fun of
let's just have a tackle football game
in the middle of this party including
the commissioner he
he got it yeah he got he got it you you
used a couple of lines and there where
he says he's
he's open yeah he was having a great
time i mean kalisha was laughing having
a good time well i mean in terms of uh
getting it i mean uh pete berg here
on the rich eisen show we're talking
about the nfl 100 commercial that he uh
that he directed for the super bowl i
mean febreze
and camaro to do the spot to celebrate
the national football league's
anniversary
i can't believe that that was shot after
the nfc right
like the day after so now i i know doing
my job
okay that sometimes when a guest sits
down like i've met you before we've
known each other for a while
so we can chit-chat before sometimes
it's that awkward silence before the
cameras go on
what in the world was it like with those
two guys sitting down
after that all happened did you bring it
up at all no i mean it was done very
quickly
and um you know
these are two breeds of professional and
i mean i
i'm not getting you know hypothesizes
you know what
was in his mind that day it was not
something that was discussed
um it was kind of like we still love
football man we're gonna do this spot
um you know we weren't we weren't we
weren't doing um a tribute to
officiating uh he wasn't asked to stand
up
and not be a heck of a commercial talk
about
the the respect that he has towards oh
why you're showing it
no no no no i know we're showing that
that's probably the worst
non-call ever i would agree with that i
said that by the way it is the worst
known call ever
and like it is i mean
what what do you like you know i mean i
i was hearing the the
you know goodell technically could have
had them replay
the game i guess i just don't think you
can do it no i mean no it's still a
human
error and i i understand i i have no
no real justification for this other
than and this is not justification but
i do think it's worth pointing out
because i've i've talked about actually
doing
something a documentary or i was talking
to
to nike about doing a spot about refs
you know just
looking at what what what the job of
officiating in the nfl is like and
for anyone who's ever stood on
on the sidelines of an nfl game uh
which i i've done just a little bit this
the speed is
is something that's not you don't get it
on television you know it's
so and they get bigger every year too
it's a combine where i'm going in two
weeks they get bigger and stronger and
faster and so they have to watch
two or three things that quickly you
know uh
whether or not a ball has been um uh you
know
secured and feet um i don't
i mean this ref obviously was having
some kind of really bad personal problem
he just was not in the game he was not
in the stadium
i don't quite understand why there's not
like a grand
jury that could that um who's the guy
dean
dean blandino formerly yeah the refs who
is dean not doing the job
no it's now it's now uh some you know
he's got a predecessor okay so it seems
like
because i've been into that control
center and in the
mcnally controls which is really like
it's a really cool place to watch and
see how they're
monitoring their officiating and with
the speed of play in all of this and
that there's
you know these games are being every one
of these games are being watched by by
the office in new york i don't know why
there's not
some sort of supreme what was in the
flintstones the poop
high exalted mystic ruler yeah why
there's that's that was i think
uh uh the honeymooners okay so what is
it it's the same thing
right the grand poobah the grand what
would you say the grand high exalted
mystic ruler so there should be the
grand high exit
exalted mystic ruler who sits there
quietly
and like um did you ever when you were
single have the um protection rule with
your friends
protection rule right so like so if you
and i are
our friends and our friends circle i can
i can
protect a girl that i'm either
interested in
or an ex-girlfriend which means you can
never go near here
ever you can't take her to dinner you
can't do it but i only get two a year
that would be the rule that we had you
could only put two there should be
one or two protected situations moments
like that yeah someone with common sense
can look at it and say okay yeah it's
not a reviewable play but
we're going to call the grand poobah and
we're going to overwhelm well your next
commercial you have the commissioner for
you bounce that off him
in a nice quiet moment i mean do you
think well it's something that people
have thrown out there's something called
a sky
judge where they're up in there's
another member of the
of the uh that's the grand poobah
they're skydiving but the problem is is
that you need to see a flag thrown
the thing that drives me crazy is
there's a play that happens you think
your team's got a first down you think
your team's gotten off the field then
all of a sudden
there's somebody calling a penalty that
you didn't even see the flag throne like
hold on a second right
if you're i'm always putting myself in
the fans seats is how they're watching
it
and whether it's acceptable or not for
them to think that somebody who's not on
the field has thrown a flag into play
and it just drives people crazy but
there needs to be something i agree with
you to fix that
um i'd love to hold you through the
break i got some uh other questions for
you one more question
on on that commercial and then we've got
a a fun start bench cut we give you
three choices
you got to start when you got to
benchmark i heard this already i don't
like it okay that's okay
you'll get through tough choices you'll
get through it peterburg here on the
rich eisen show don't you dare move
uh and also when we come back on the
television show audience we did we
showed this to billy bob thornton
when he was here that's right our our uh
rich eisen show
super bowl show opened from when we were
in houston a couple of years ago
from friday night lights and i want to
show that to you that's next here on the
rich eisen show
all right well the radio audience is
away peter i showed this to billy bob
thornton when he was here
last year a couple years ago our show
opened
for the super bowl in houston we figured
we're going to texas i need to pay
homage to one of my favorite films
you directed it take a look i want your
honest opinion
look each other in the eyes put each
other in your scripts
forever because forever is about to
happen
this week in houston boys
my heart is full my host
chair is full now let's go out there and
[Applause]
broadcast
wow uh energy yeah
um you you took your time you i believed
you
okay rousing my heart's pounding mm-hmm
well done
thank you sir well done that's how about
that i'll bend all of you
by the way i got the check mark from
billy bob too he's he he gave me the
check mark
i think he might need to pay me a check
i'm going to check
how about the money i don't want to
check mark i want to check
okay we'll look into that i'll see y'all
it's very good but yeah we you know we
we figured to do that you
you were on crutches right mike you were
boobie he was booby
you were booby yeah mike del tufo is
booby
i um one of one of the like
this is a weird business you know we and
you never know quite how
um how doing what we do impacts people
and i i know that friday night lights is
you know popular show and i was um
it never it never ceased to to surprise
me or at least i hadn't
have people come up to me and they quote
things and like things and
i was at ultra music festival in miami
which is
not my thing i took i was being cool dad
and i took my son
and a bunch of his friends and it's an
electronic music festival which i just
can't quite get my head around but i was
being a good dad and i took them down
there
and i was in this back area and ezekiel
elliott came up to me
and he said you you worked on friday
night lights
and i said yeah and he uh he goes i got
to show you something
and he took his t-shirt off and he had
uh
booby miles tattooed on his left and
god-given on his right and those were
lines from the movie
and i was like damn that's that's legit
did you tell him you wanted him to lose
twice a year against you johnson
that was an appropriate moment i didn't
tell him that i didn't tell him i wanted
but i do have a warm spot in my heart
for for ezekiel there you go
we're back with the radio audience in a
moment
all right welcome back to the rich
eysing show the actress lena heady from
fighting with my family in game of
thrones is going to join us in hour
number three but one last segment here
with the director
uh peter berg good to see you again sir
appreciate you sticking around last
question for you on the nfl 100
commercial is
uh for that you added the super bowl how
did you decide who got in and who didn't
i mean there had to be so much that hit
the cutting room floor how difficult was
that process i mean i was um
no nobody hit their cutting room floor i
think we owed tony gonzalez
anyone got a slight short change tony
gonzalez went into the cake
but we you can barely tell that it's him
um that
i finally told tracy to stop i said
don't
remember the commercial was originally
gonna be 62nd then we got so many
athletes it was 90
and then at the very end i'm like guys
and it's gotta be two minutes
and they gave us two minutes um which is
you know for anyone that follows the
that's a lot of money that's a lot
that's an extra 30 seconds is a ton of
money
that's a that's a big bowl of meatballs
and
um we finally had to stop because you
couldn't have someone come out there and
show up and film them and not be in it
so everybody everybody's in it but tony
i
i think we all cause you can't really
see his face clear enough well last
question i lied uh
is there an item a memorabilia item
where everybody signed it gold football
that goldfish everybody got a gold
football yeah the football that fell
yeah and they did uh an incredible um
photograph which reminds me i got to get
it of all
i think it's 48 players
lined up holding their football it's an
incredible so everybody got a football
i'm going to send you one
we'll put it right up here it'll look
great here yeah i love it everybody got
a football so but what i'm saying is
is there one item where everybody signed
though i think that it's the um everyone
signed one big picture
the the poster that's i mean it's where
is that now i'm gonna get you one
okay the answer is thank you nick we
gotta get that
okay yeah correct nick let's get on that
please okay
all right uh a four question start bench
cut for
peter berg here on the richter it's time
to start shut down
bench just sit down and be quiet or cut
up okay here we go
four items hit the music please uh you
have to start when bench one cut one
best movie quarterback willie beamon
from any given sunday
shane falco from the replacements or
jonathan moxen from varsity blues we
left mike winchell out because we know
you'd choose him
best movie quarterback out of the three
but varsity blues who was the actor
it's our guy right over there right
vanderbilt james vanderbilt
james randori i mean i'm gonna go with
jamie i'm gonna i'm gonna um
start jamie foxx yeah just because he's
just
the the will to win is constant as bruce
lee would say okay
keanu god i love him but he's gone a
little too john wick for me
and i don't i don't you caught him uh
yeah no i'm in a bench
i'm gonna bench him i like that he's
still okay he's still got the
he's a violent guy obviously and um
um moxen i just
i don't know i i feel like
the turk's visiting him you cut him it
might be time for him to
okay to go somewhere else okay next one
for uh pete berg in a few minutes we
have left here
weirdest mark wahlberg quirk okay
waking up at 2 30 in the morning
showering twice a day or the daily cryo
chamber recovery
start bench cut oh god which do i cut
uh i mean i i just love anyone that gets
up at 2 30
uh in the morning i i get up i don't get
up that early but i'm a big i'm a big
believer in early rising okay always
so mark getting up at 2 30. i respect
i'm going to keep that
i'm definitely going to cut the cry out
i don't think cryo does anything
okay i have a house i go skiing all the
time if i want cryo i you know and it's
horrible
how cold it is up there in montana and
it doesn't i don't feel better
i get cryo every time i i open my door
in montana
and those people like oh i'm going to
get cry or recovering i'm like
first of all what are you recovering
from really do you really need your
recovery
i mean i like this buzzword that's going
around now recovery and it's like okay
so you cut that cut the crop is gone
start the wake up and then two showers a
day is it necessary no and we have water
problems and shortages so okay i think
mark
i would i would bench but definitely
keep to 2 30. okay
uh let's skip to the last one since we
have only time for one more
uh pete berg start bench cup the
starting quarterback for the 2019 new
york giants
ohio state's dwayne haskins the
heisman trophy winner kyle murray or eli
so we keep eli fernandez we we draft
um dwayne okay uh we we we bench him
we keep eli who had a good year last
year um
and kyler goes elsewhere okay so you
start eli bench dwayne haskins and cut
kylie murray yeah all right there you go
but we're probably getting nick falls
and now he's going to break
i don't know if the eagles are going to
lose or who's or um
cardinals rosen josh rose yeah we got
josh frozen i don't know you gotta
if they draft murray that guy is a
patriot fan over there he wants joshua
josh yeah to be the to be the next
person next brady yeah
i don't know that's not there's there is
no next brady that's what you're gonna
have to understand
just get ready yeah i mean all due
respect to brian hoyer i'd rather have
joshua that was so great
it's gonna rain in new england for a
long time in boston
get ready it's gonna rain for a long
time the minute i have left were those
were those all
real rings from
he now has a sixth but those were really
his super bowl rings that he handed to
baker mayfield in the commercial
incredible coolest moment
he's quite a man tom brady baker must
have loved that too right he must have
soaked that they were all
just having a great time and you know i
think well it's a great
a great spot and we're gonna beat it
next year it's a great great spot
pete uh and i love having you on this
show thanks for coming in here and uh
and hanging with us for for much of the
second hour all right so when we come
back i want to check in on the
machado situation to see if he's
actually in san diego or not
the latest from a news update and then
uh queen cersei herself is here
so del tufo no shame no shame don't say
that to her okay
lena headey is in studio hour number
three talking about her new new movie
fighting with my family that's coming up
here on the rich eisen show the rich
eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience